et ceci nous amène au déraillement de la
motrice d'une rame de tgv qui s'est
produit ce matin près de laval une
coulée de boue sur les voies à
immobiliser sans violence le train qui
transportait quelques 500 voyageurs
pas de blessés mais de fortes
perturbations dans le trafic ferroviaire
le point sur cet accident et sur les
inondations qui touchent le nil et
vilaine et le finistère plan soupire
cette coulée de boue en pleine voie
le tgv brest paris n'a pu l'éviter ce
matin quand le chauffeur du train la
découvre il n'en est plus qu'à 300
mètres
le choc est rude mais heureusement sans
conséquence grave
je décollais de 50 cm à peu près de mon
siège mais vous reliez vite 100 120 150
à peu près jeu j'ai pas le temps de
vérifier les passagers en sont quittes
pour quelques heures de retard le temps
pour un second tgv de venir à leur
rescousse
ce déraillement n'est que l'une des
conséquences des intempéries qui
bouleverse à nouveau la bretagne dans le
finistère à quimper
tout un secteur de la ville est
totalement inondé et le trafic
ferroviaire commence à être sérieusement
perturbée
non aussi regard de l'eau monte et la
loire et l'erdre gonfle inexorablement
mais pour l'instant seule la rocade est
de la ville est fermée à la circulation
c'est en ille et vilaine à
saint-nicolas-de-redon que l'on se
prépare au pire
la ville s'est presque résigné à avoir
les pieds noyés depuis que je suis là
c'est la quatrième ça fait 13 ans que je
suis là 4e inondations la cote d' alerte
devrait être atteint d'ici demain matin
alors on s'organise les services de la
ville livres à domicile les parpaings
qui permettront peut-être de sauver les
meubles